[Music]
everyone wants to try if they've never
done
it you spend your life shaving your
beard
off the moment has come for everyone to
try because it's become so
popular hi well is Alex Clover I'm
Master Barber here at
Murdoch it's a bit of a myth that um
having a beard is a kind of lazy version
of of grooming actually takes a lot of
work to keep a beard looking sharp you
know if you want to kind of keep a keep
looking sexy with a beard then you need
to slim down the sides and slim down the
chin so the trick is to decide to gra
your beard do it just before a holiday
Stop Shaving and then that way you'd
come back from work with a reasonably
good
coverage naturally um with Trends you
always get a reaction so the reaction to
over grooming in in that metrosexual
sense is to kind of go the other way and
you know broom out broom
bigger yeah I'd say you know with
November the uh the general consensus is
that you start the month with a clean
shave and then you've got a month to
grow it unfortunately in real terms that
means you won't get enough hair to do a
lot with it within a month so I'm all
about
cheating so maybe start growing a little
bit before and have a full shave
everywhere
else I suppose subconsciously what
you're saying is um I can do what I like
I'm free of the shackles of you know
corporate kind of uh image I
suppose